it's the sweetheart deal heard around
the world Hunter Biden avoiding prison
after pleading guilty and cutting a deal
for his tax and gun crimes dad's
campaign would like the issue to go away
but GOP candidates have other plans you
look at this Hunter Biden case today
yeah that's a gun law that was on the
books that if you are a drug user or
drug abuser you're not allowed to apply
for a gun permit now that law seems to
make perfect sense
except today we're seeing it's not being
enforced it's dangerous let me just say
we all know this that the big guy has
some explaining to do Tim Scott
the media thinks that if you attack
Hunter though you're a big old jerk and
that the first son should have gotten
off easy
if this wasn't Hunter Biden it is likely
he wouldn't have been prosecuted at all
it's not going to stop you all from
going after Biden everybody knows that
you don't have to tell us we know you're
going to keep looking because you're
Lookers this is painful for the
president personally and politically he
is a devoted father who has stood by his
son throughout his struggles with
addiction throughout this investigation
adamant that Hunter did absolutely
nothing wrong but it is clear
Republicans are not going to drop this
what do these jerks in the house want
Joe Biden to do throw him out refuse to
speak to him say he doesn't love him
publicly do they not understand this
disease and how it works a disease now
do you buy this Hunter's lawyer says he
isn't too sure if the infamous laptop
from hell was part of the investigation
do you have any idea if
um Hunter Biden's laptop had anything to
do with this investigation was it used I
don't I can't recall being asked about
it to be honest with you
um but there's nothing about the the
situation that's being that's been filed
that has a thing to do with the laptop
why not
I don't know you'd have to ask the
prosecutors see judge this raises an
important point that the plea deal
intentionally or not steers all the
focus onto what was settled and nobody's
really like talking about what was left
on the table which I mean what was given
up in this process everything was given
up you see if they can say and by the
way he doesn't strike me as a Real
Genius there but that's another issue uh
number one uh if you were negotiating a
plea deal you know all about all of the
evidence the prosecutor has because he's
going to use it as leverage the the the
U.S attorney is going to say we got him
on this this and this so you better
plead to this and this they're not he
said it never came up it never came up
as corroboration of everything that
we've been talking about it's
circumstantial evidence it proves that
the investigation was not a a real
investigation it was something that they
were holding until now where you got two
misdemeanors and you you know everybody
says oh it's no big deal and it's
painful for the president yeah because
he he's not getting his ten percent
anymore of course it's painful for the
president and this whole thing is in in
Clapper now saying about the laptop that
I haven't seen anything to disprove it
wasn't Russian information they're
doubling down on this look the the feds
are leaving and saying that the case is
still open so Congress cannot subpoena
the records that's why they're doing it
but there's another reason I think also
if we get another Administration in
they're going to be able to identify the
money laundering the pharah the law
being the foreign agent lobbying all of
that other stuff the financial
transactions and they're going to say
this administration had it but didn't it
didn't do anything with it well speaking
of the future Administration Tulsi this
is a theory posited by a friend of mine
that now Joe can step aside because he
know it no longer needs to Pardon Hunter
Biden so now he can go home is that just
a crazy Theory I don't think anything is
crazy at this point you know I think the
as far as this election goes I think
it's less about Joe Biden than it is
about Kamala Harris coming in as as
president but this whole thing
unfortunately just further undermines
the rule of law people's faith that we
have Law and Order in this country and
that the justice system actually means
anything and so there are too many
examples now to cite but this is yet the
latest in in recognizing that we have an
Administration and people in power who
are willing to direct that power against
their political opponent and also like
every other dictatorship in the country
direct that power to protect those that
they want to protect in this case you
know it's Hunter Biden and and obviously
this sends the wrong message to the
American people but more dangerously it
undermines that Foundation of our
democracy which is that fair justice
system that rule of law you know though
I noticed something really positive
about the media Jesse uh here's a case
of a white guy getting special treatment
and they didn't scream systemic racism
no that's a good point so they're
they're
no longer blaming that on racism We Have
Tonight ja rules attorney Ja Rule paid
no taxes on the same amount of money
that Hunter did and he got sentenced to
two years in prison right
what do you think the difference is
between Ja Rule and Hunter Biden are you
going to show us we'll see you tonight I
don't like it when they say this disease
he smokes crack if if if everybody that
did drugs
didn't pay their taxes we'd have no
Revenue that is so true drugs that's not
an excuse this entire table the feds are
never going to crack open the laptop as
long as Joe Biden's President Joe Biden
his administration is not going to
investigate corruption in the Biden
family it's just not going to happen
plus the FBI and the CIA has this is
blackmail they can just dangle it in
front of Joe and he has to do whatever
they say or else Boop there it goes open
the only way it comes open if a
republican gets into the White House and
so they're going to do everything they
can to prevent a republican from getting
into the White House because the laptop
is basically tells everybody how guilty
the entire system is the House
Republicans are now looking at these
heavily redacted additional FBI
informant pieces of paper that Chris Ray
is still trying to hide and we're still
looking at more bank records if you had
an impeachment inquiry open up that can
speed up the subpoena process the
witness process but the House
Republicans don't feel like it's ripe
enough to do it right now they want to
let Comer do a little bit more work
but the bottom line is that insiders
protect insiders you said it the other
day
Trump's an outsider he goes to prison
his people go to prison but if you're
Washington Insider you get the hunter
Biden treatment exactly and we just have
to accept that reality right it has
nothing to do with wealth it has to do
with status and power yeah Dana let's
talk about we didn't bring up Hunter's
stripper baby which I swear I wasn't
going to say stripper baby baby is not a
stripper the baby is not a stripper and
I I so I I apologize it's the baby's
baby of a former stripper uh an
entertainment worker here's the deal
somehow he worked it out so that the
baby can't have his last name because
he's worried that the baby might soil
the name Biden
this is the thing I honestly I it upsets
me the most on behalf of the girl
because she's an innocent child who
happened to be fathered by Hunter bidens
and that Hunter Biden has a family now
and he gets to go to the White House and
fly on Air Force One and he gets to be
with all the you know his children are
with all the cousins and they get all
the benefits of being being the Biden
family but forget that the perks what
about the love and the the father and
and for the bidens the the president and
the first lady it's hard for me to
imagine that you don't want to hold this
girl and yesterday when you got this
plea deal and then they settled that
thing and now he only has to pay five
thousand dollars a month in child
support that's what that's what this
woman agreed to maybe there was
something else behind the scenes we
don't have those details I wish the
mother well I wish the baby well and I
wish that the internet did not exist
when she gets old enough to read
exactly hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else